in the fight against the coronavirus
there is still one big unknown how many
people have actually contracted it maybe
even without showing any symptoms one
way to answer the question is by
antibody tests an antibody is a
protective protein produced by the
immune system to destroy for example
harmful viruses when a pathogen enters
the human body the immune system
recognizes it and produces antibodies
that dock onto the pathogens anti genes
to remove them later a test can be used
to detect these antibodies in a person's
bloodstream antibodies are also used in
vaccines to make people immune to future
infections but immunity doesn't always
last a lifetime so what do we know about
SARS Cove - and how long will people be
immune after an infection these will be
some of our topics on this edition of
kovat 19 special here on DW news I'm
Crisco Burton Berlin welcome to the
program
now in the quest to fight the corona
virus a small town in Germany could
provide valuable answers hein speck in
the state of North rhine-westphalia has
become an epicenter of the current
health crisis now scientists are using
the town as a testing ground to find out
how kovat 19 has spread and how to move
forward the streets are empty in Hinds
Park the town on germany's western
border with holland has become the
epicenter of the coronavirus crisis in
the country it was here that the virus
spread at a local carnival infecting
dozens of citizens and putting the town
in the focus of politicians and
biologists alike
the kites Hinesburg Hinesburg offers the
unique opportunity to us because the
virus arrived here on a very specific
date on February 14 or 15 during
carnival based on this we have
sufficient data for example to determine
unrecorded cases at some bar business
Hinesburg has become a case study for
covered 19 and the question how can we
go back to normal a lot depends on how
patients develop immunity to covet 19
through antibodies to find out mouth
swabs and blood tests were conducted on
1,000 locals and 15% of the population
of the municipality here can no longer
be infected with SARS cava to ask for
bids via Oscar Belitung there has been
some criticism that the study might not
be representative of other regions also
some experts fear it might be too early
to say whether or not antibodies prevent
further infections with corona virus
we'll talk to a leading scientists here
in a moment if and if so how the search
for antibodies can help the fight
against kovat 19 first a quick reminder
what exactly we mean when we talk about
antibodies antibodies are produced by
the immune system to neutralize
pathogens when for example a virus
enters the body the immune system
produces specific antibodies that dock
on to the virus's anti genes to remove
it now these antibodies can be detected
in a person's bloodstream later on so
let's take a closer look at the matter
with Jacques Houser he's a professor of
Epidemiology at the Helmholtz Centre for
infection research it's good to have you
on the program thus finding antibodies
mean that the pathogen has been
eliminated that the infection is over
reflect the fact that the immune system
has had contact with the pathogen and
often also reflected later on after the
disease has been passed in overcome that
then the body is immune at least for
certain time against new infection so
how does detecting these antibodies help
us against the fight against the corona
virus here ok so this helps at multiple
levels on population level and also at
individual level so a population level
if we know how many percent of the
population do have antibodies we do also
know that those people will not be able
to transmit and be part of the
duplication and transmission process of
the epidemic anymore so this helps and
assessing what kind of measures we need
to do it also helps us in determining
how many percent of the cases that we
are counting to actually exist and that
in turn helps us to assess how many
cases are dying in proportion to the
cases it actually exists so all those
figures are very important for the
assessment of the risk of the epidemic
but also for the assessment of the
strategies to fight against the pandemic
now some experts say this this antibody
test don't deliver accurate enough
results that antibodies against other
forms of Kuran coronavirus get detected
and then get mistaken this is correct so
so far the currently available antibody
tests have some cost reactivity reaction
to the to the other coronaviruses and it
is difficult to assess how large this
fader or this percentage actually is we
hope that in the future and actually my
lab is working on that your antibody
test will be available that will be more
precise and more specific hmm and there
are reports about potential
re-infections despite the people
supposedly being immune
what are we to make of that well I think
the reports so far they don't imply that
people
reinfection despite of being being
immune they only that tests of detection
was vials as possible after people have
recovered and that is yet another thing
so not necessarily does a person that we
covers or that health has had a negative
test result in the virus detection
necessarily have immunity probably
infection or it doesn't also mean that
the contrary is the case so we need to
look into that and more in more deaths
we need to look at the antibody
detection of those patients and then we
need to also see whether those patients
who had we identification and detection
of pathogens who actually got ill or
betras carriers of the pathogen you know
for many other diseases that people may
be carriers of a disease or a pathogen
without actually falling you know huh is
there a way to determine how long
immunity will last in terms of SARS
cough - I'm afraid the only way this is
time we need to look at the patients who
have had the disease at one point in
time from which you have antibodies from
a given point in time and then we have
to wait and look into the future whether
there are cases among those who do get
the disease again now your institution
wants to conduct antibody testing
similar to the one we've seen in the
report but on a much larger scale what
do you hope to show by doing that so by
the colleagues in Heinberg have done a
very important study with a very
specific focus in a very exclusive
locality we try to do number of studies
at different time points and in
different localities in the country in
order to give a better reflection on the
immunity level in the overall population
but also on the change of that immunity
level over time and by that we hope to
be guiding politics and policy makers
and decision makers on how to adjust the
interventions in the fight against a
pandemic
there are calls of the Helmholtz Centre
for infection research thank you for
sharing your thoughts with us
and now to a staple segment in our show
you send us your questions about the
coronavirus we try to answer them and
the man hard at work in doing so is our
science editor Derek Williams I can ask
this a lot it's it's something that
worries people let's put it this way
there's no evidence so far suggesting
that take out or take away food
contributes in any way to COBIT 19
transmission there are no reported cases
that have been linked to food
there aren't any full-blown studies yet
on kovat 19 but there have been some
similar studies on this topic with other
coronaviruses and they showed that
transmission in those pathogens doesn't
really happen via the digestive tract in
the first stages of the infection at
least coronaviruses in general invade
the cells in the upper respiratory tract
Sarris cove 2 also often appears to gain
its first foothold in the nose which
food doesn't enter of course viruses
that are swallowed in food end up in the
digestive tract and are eventually
killed by the acid in your stomach so as
far as we can tell
takeaway food doesn't present a danger
Packaging probably presents slightly
more of one that's why many experts also
say if you want to be extra safe you can
transfer takeout food to your own
household dishes dispose of the
containers quickly and of course then
wash your hands thoroughly
we still don't know everything there is
to know about the transmission of source
co2 but we're learning all the time and
as far as we can tell there's no way to
get kovat 19 from drinking water the
w-h-o says there's no evidence about the
survival of the virus in either potable
water or sewage and other Karuna viruses
are not transmitted this way source co2
is actually what's called an enveloped
virus which means it has a quite fragile
membrane that doesn't protect it all
that long outside the body standard
treatment methods used in most municipal
drinking water systems like filtration
and disinfection should inactivate it
just like they do other pathogens if you
live somewhere where you don't have
access to safe treated drinking water
then the precautions that you've always
taken to protect yourself like boiling
your drinking water should also
inactivate any corona virus I can't
really give any correct advice here as
buying food is so different from country
to country and and from culture to
culture but speaking for myself in the
coronavirus age going to the grocery
store has turned into a pretty
nerve-wracking experience it's really
hard I find to keep the proper minimum
distance away from other shoppers even
if the stores like here in Germany are
limiting the number of customers allowed
in at any given time in general though
many experts are saying it's best to buy
big when you do go shopping as going to
the store less often limits your
exposure to a potentially contagious
environment but if you are going on a
big shopping trip it's good to restrain
the urge to fear by huge amounts of
basic necessities like toilet paper
try to strike the right balance between
meeting your own needs and respecting
the needs of others we're all in this
together